THAT IS DEVELOPING TODAY.
26 REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS NOW
WANT ACTION AND THEY ARE NOW
DEMANDING PRESIDENT BIDEN MEET
WITH THEM WITHIN THE NEXT TWO
WEEKS.
YEAH, THEY HAVE A DEADLINE ON
THIS.
THEY'VE WRITTEN A LETTER ALL
TOGETHER AND YOU SEE AT THE END
OF THE LETTER THEY'VE ALL
SIGNED IT AS CHIEF EXECUTIVES
OF OUR STATES WE REQUEST A
MEETING WITH YOU AT THE WHITE
HOUSE TO BRING AN END TO THE
NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS
CREATED BY EIGHT MONTHS OF
UNENFORCED BORDERS.
IT'S ABOUT A PAGE AND A HALF.
THREE GOVERNORS ARE IN FOCUS
NOW.
DOUG DOOCY OF ARIZONA,
HUTCHINSON OF ARKANSAS AND KEMP
OF GEORGIA.
GOVERNOR DOOCY I WANT TO START
WITH A LETTER AND FIND OUT WHAT
YOU HOPE TO ACCOMPLISH.
WE CAN'T EVEN GET THE PRESIDENT
TO TAKE OUR QUESTIONS IN THE
PRESS.
>> IT IS TIME FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO ACT.
BORDER SECURITY HAS BEEN SEEN
AS SOMETHING THAT THE SOUTHERN
STATES HAVE TO DEAL WITH ON THE
BORDER.
THE REASON THAT YOU HAVE
GOVERNOR HUTCHINSON AND
GOVERNOR KEMP FROM ARKANSAS AND
GEORGIA IS BECAUSE SOMETHING
THAT HAS BECOME NATIONAL
SECURITY BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
WHO IS COMING OVER THE BORDER
AND HAS BECOME PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE DRUGS AND CRIME WE'RE
SEEING RISING IN OUR STATES AND
FLOODING OVER THE BORDER IS
INFECTING OUR SCHOOLS AND
NEIGHBORHOODS.
MORE THAN HALF THE NATION'S
GOVERNORS, ALL REPUBLICAN, HAVE
DEMANDED A MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT BIDE THAN.
-- BIDEN.
IT IS A FEDERAL ISSUE.
WE WANT TO WORK WITH THEM BUT
THE TIME FOR ACTION IS RIGHT
NOW.
>> Harris: THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS NOT RESPONDING TO
REQUEST FOR HELP AND ALL OF IT
GOVERNOR KEMP.
AT ONE POINT YOU WOULD THINK
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE WOULD GET
BACK WITH A PLAN.
THEY DID SEND FEMA SEVERAL
MONTHS AGO AND NOW THEY'VE
ASKED FOR MORE TROOPS.
BUT WE HAVE -- FOR SOME TROOPS.
WE HAVE A SITUATION THAT'S MORE
URGENT THAN A PLAN ON A WALL.
>> WELL HARRIS, WE HAVE OVER
200 GEORGIA NATIONAL GUARD
TROOPS DOWN THERE NOW AND HAVE
BEEN FOR A LONG TIME.
I VISITED THEM BACK AT THE END
OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
WHAT IS HAPPENING NOW AND WHAT
HAS HAPPENED SEVERAL MONTHS AGO
IN McALLEN, TEXAS, DRASTICALLY
DIFFERENT BECAUSE THE POLICIES
HAVE CHANGED.
THE MESSAGING CHANGED FROM THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND THEY
NEED TO ACT.
WE'RE GLAD TO SEND MORE TROOPS
BUT THE QUESTION TO ME OR THE
TAPE EARLIER ABOUT THE
APPREHENSIONS, WHAT ABOUT THE
PEOPLE THAT AREN'T BEING
APPREHENDED?
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE COMING
ACROSS UNDETECTED?
IT'S THE GOVERNORS WHO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
>> Harris: WE STRUGGLE TO GET
EXACT NUMBERS IN REALTIME AND
THEY'LL RELEASE A NUMBER AT THE
END OF EACH MONTH BUT IT HELPS
TO KNOW IN REALTIME.
WE KNOW IT'S 3,000 PEOPLE EVERY
DAY NOW THAT ARE TRYING TO GET
INTO THIS COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT PUT THE VICE
PRESIDENT IN CHARGE OF THIS,
THOUGH.
I WANT TO GET TO THIS AND
GOVERNOR HUTCHINSON I WILL COME
TO YOU.
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
SPEAKING OUT NOW ON THE BORDER
CRISIS BUT ONLY TO CONDEMN
BORDER PATROL AGENTS ON THE
FRONT LINES WHO WERE ACCUSED OF
MISTREATING HAITIAN MIGRANTS IN
DEL RIO.
>> WHAT I SAW DEPICTED OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ON HORSE BACK
TREATING HUMAN BEINGS THE WAY
THEY WERE IS HORRIBLE.
AND I FULLY SUPPORT WHAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW WHICH IS A
FEDERAL INVESTIGATION.
HUMAN BEINGS SHOULD NEVER BE
TREATED THAT WAY AND I'M DEEPLY
TROUBLED ABOUT IT.
>> Harris: CURIOUS TO KNOW HOW
MUCH DIGGING IN TO THE FACTS
THEY HAVE DONE.
THE DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN FROM
TEXAS, HENRY CUELLAR DEFENDED
THE BORDER PATROL OFFICIALS,
WATCH.
>> IF THERE WAS A PROBLEM IT
SHOULD BE INVESTIGATED AND
THAT'S IT.
BUT WE CANNOT PAINT THE BORDER
PATROL WITH THE SAME TYPE OF
PAINT BRUSH.
WHAT ARE THEY SUPPOSED TO DO,
JUST STAND THERE AND LET
EVERYBODY COME?
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
ENFORCING THE LAW.
>> Harris: THIS HAS BEEN GOING
ON FOR EIGHT MONTHS AND THE ONE
INCIDENT THAT THIS VICE
PRESIDENT LEANS IN ON IS
SOMETHING THAT AS YOU HEARD A
DEMOCRAT SAYS SIMPLY NEEDS TO
BE INVESTIGATED.
IT IS NOT THE WHOLE THING OF
WHAT'S GOING THE BOARD ARE.
>> BORDER PATROL IS WHAT IS
STANDING AND SUPPORTING OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
WE NEED TO SUPPORT OUR BORDER
PATROL.
THEY'RE DOING AN AMAZING JOB
WITH DIFFICULT CHALLENGES.
AS A CONGRESSMAN SAID IF THERE
IS ANY ISSUE IT CAN BE REVIEWED.
BY AND LARGE THEY HAVE A VERY
DIFFICULT JOB.
LET ME EMPHASIZE A COUPLE OF
POINTS.
FIRST OF ALL, THIS ALL STARTED
AS GOVERNOR DOOCY SAID BECAUSE
THERE IS A CHANGE OF POLICY IN
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THE WRONG SIGNAL WAS SENT TO
OUR COUNTERPARTS AIF CROSS THE
GLOBE THAT WE HAVE AN OPEN
BORDER AND THIS IS THE RESULT
OF IT THAT IS A BORDER IN CHAOS.
THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN REVERSE
THAT AND I THIS I THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SEES THE NEED TO
DO IT, IS THAT YOU HAVE TO
CHANGE POLICY.
BUT EVEN MORE SIGNIFICANTLY YOU
HAVE TO PUT FEDERAL RESOURCES
THERE THAT SENDS THE SIGNAL
THAT WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT
PROTECTING THE BORDER.
THESE ARE NOT COMPLICATED STEPS.
THESE NEED TO BE DONE.
THE FACT THAT 26 GOVERNORS HAVE
SIGNED THAT LETTER IS A STRONG
SIGNAL THAT THIS IS A MESS AND
ADVERSELY IMPACTING ALL OF OUR
STATES.
>> Harris: I WANT TO TALK NOW
ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS OF YOU
HAVING TO KNOCK ON THE DOOR OF
THE WHITE HOUSE, FOR LACK OF A
BETTER TERM WHEN YOU WRITE A
LETTER LIKE THE ONE YOU'VE
WRITTEN.
GOVERNOR KEMP, THAT HAS TO BE
AN OUTLIER IN HOW NORMAL
BUSINESS IS DONE.
I HAVE TO THINK THERE IS SOME
LEVEL OF FRUSTRATION THAT IT
HAS COME TO THIS.
NORMALLY YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO
PICK UP THE PHONE, RIGHT?
YOU ARE A CHIEF EXECUTIVE OF
YOUR STATES REACHING OUT TO OUR
NATION'S CHIEF EXECUTIVE.
I WOULD IMAGINE HE WOULD WANT
TO TAKE A CALL.
>> THE FRUSTRATING THING FOR
ME, HARRIS, WHEN YOU ARE IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH THE CITIZENS
OF YOUR STATE AND COUNTRY WANT
TO TAKE ACTION WHEN THERE IS A
CRISIS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND THIS TASK FORCE I
HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING FROM THEM
ABOUT ANY POLICY POSITIONS OR
CHANGE IN ANYTHING FROM THE
DISASTER THAT WE'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW.
THIS CURRENT SITUATION IN DEL
RIO, THIS IS JUST ONE OF THE
EXAMPLES.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON, AS YOU
MENTIONED, FOR MONTHS AND
MONTHS.
WE'RE WILLING TO HELP.
I AM WILLING AND THE GEORGIA
NATIONAL GUARD TO SEND MORE
PEOPLE BUT THEY HAVE TO ASK FOR
THAT.
IT IS NOT AS IF WE'RE DEMANDING
SOMETHING.
WE WANT TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION AS WELL.
THIS IS A FEDERAL ISSUE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
SUPPOSED TO PROTECT OUR BORDERS.
WE'VE BEEN GLAD TO HELP.
THE TEXAS STATE TROOPERS HAVE
TO PATROL THE BORDER BECAUSE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL NOT.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
THE STATES WILL DEAL WITH GANG
MEMBERS AND DRUGS AND OTHER
THINGS FLOODING OVER THE
BORDERS.
>> Harris: IT IS ALREADY
HAPPENING WHICH IS WHY YOU HAVE
BANDED TOGETHER.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE THE
VIDEO FROM OVER THE WEEKEND.
THEY HAD TO TAKE PATROL CARS,
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND BORDER
PATROL TO STOP THE PEOPLE
FLOWING INTO THE COUNTRY.
THEY HAD TO BUILD A BARRICADE
OF VEHICLES TO KEEP THE HUMAN
BEINGS FROM CROSSING INTO THE
COUNTRY.
THEY ALL HAVE TO BE PROCESSED.
NOW WE LEARN, GOVERNOR DUCEY,
WE KNOW FROM GOVERNORS KEMP AND
HUTCHINSON IT WILL FAN OUT IN
WAYS OF DRUG CARTELS AND SEX
TRAFFICKING AND THOSE HORRIBLE
SITUATION.
THE IMMEDIACY IS WHAT ABOUT
THOSE FAMILIES LIVING ALONG THE
BORDER?
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO THEM,
GOVERNOR DUCEY AND WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO THEIR LIVES?
>> THESE RANCHERS ARE UNDER
ASSAULT.
THEIR WAY OF LIFE HAS
DRAMATICALLY CHANGED.
THIS WHITE HOUSE DOESN'T LISTEN
TO GOVERNORS.
IT DOESN'T VALUE GOVERNORS OR
TALK TO THE GOVERNORS.
IT LOOKS AT US AS LOWER MIDDLE
MANAGERS IN THEIR FEDERAL
CORPORATION.
WHERE IS KILOMETER?
-- KAMALA HARRIS?
SHE HASN'T COME TO ARIZONA.
MAYORKAS IS NON-RESPONSIVE AND
BIDEN IS TRYING TO CHANGE THE
NEWS DOING VACCINE MANDATES.
WE'LL PARTNER WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
WE HAVE SENT LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
PLACES LIKE ARIZONA AND TEXAS
AND WE'RE GRATEFUL BUT WE NEED
THE FULL FAITH AND FORCE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND WE
SHOULD BE SUPPORTING THE BORDER
PATROL.
THEY'RE DOWN THERE, WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION GIVING THEM 19th
CENTURY TECHNOLOGY WHEN WE KNOW
THAT WALLS WORK, WE KNOW THAT
DRONES WORK, WE KNOW THAT
SURVEILLANCE WORKS AND THEN
THERE SHOULD BE A CLEAR MESSAGE
THE BORDER IS NOT OPEN.
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS
BOTH RAISED THEIR HAND IN THE
FIRST DEBATE AND SAID THEY
WOULD OFFER FREE HEALTHCARE TO
PEOPLE THAT ILLEGALLY CROSSED
THE BORDER.
THEY NEED TO CORRECT THEIR
MESSAGING RIGHT AWAY.
>> Harris: CAN WE GET THEM
VACCINATED IF WE LET THEM FAN
OUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY?
WE ARE OEF IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC.
DOES THE WHITE HOUSE CARE OR
NOT?
WE'LL MAKE SURE WE FOLLOW YOU.
ANY GOVERNOR CAN TAKE THAT.
>> THAT'S THE OTHER PART OF
THIS.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE NATIONAL
SECURITY CRISIS AND THE PUBLIC
SAFETY CRISIS.
YOU CAN SEE THE HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS WHEN YOU LOOK AT DEL RIO.
THAT SHOULD BE LABELED
BIDENVILLE UNTIL THEY CLEAN
THIS UP.
AND THEN THERE IS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING.
WE'RE ALL BATTLING, PROMOTING
AND ADVOCATING VACCINES TRYING
TO KEEP OUR CITIZENS SAFE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION SEEMS TO
FORGET ABOUT THAT AS PEOPLE
COME OVER THE BORDER ILLEGALLY.
THEY SHOULD BE RETURNING THEM
TO THEIR COUNTRY.
THEY SHOULD BE ENFORCING TITLE
42.
THEY SHOULD BE FINISHING THE
WALL AND THEY SHOULD BE SENDING
A CLEAR MESSAGE THAT THE BORDER
IS NOT OPEN.
>> Harris: THANK YOU FOR GIVING
OUR VIEWERS ON "THE FAULKNER
FOCUS" AN IDEA OF EXACTLY WHAT
YOU WILL SAY TO THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD YOU SIT DOWN.
QUICKLY ANYBODY HEARD FROM THE
PRESIDENT SINCE YOU SENT YOUR
LETTER?
YES OR NO.
>> NO.
>> NOTHING.
>> WE HAVEN'T YET.
>> Harris: THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
CHIEF EXECUTIVES IN YOUR STATE,
THREE OF 26 DEMANDING A MEETING
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Harris: DID YOU HEAR HIM